vinieron a obtener garantías los
miembros de la delegación de la onu
finalmente se van con un plazo en
diciembre las autoridades de transición
de malí confirmarán la fecha de las
próximas elecciones presidenciales y
legislativas el consejo de seguridad de
la onu exige que se respeten los plazos
electorales y el retorno de los civiles
al poder
el expreso su convicción de que la
transición no durará no hay una agenda
oculta los malienses votarán tan pronto
se cumplan las condiciones
la fecha del 27 de febrero inicialmente
fijada parece difícil de sostener los
militares al frente del país desde mayo
pasado han mostrado su disposición a
posponer la fecha desean organizar de
antemano asambleas nacionales del 21 al
26 de diciembre para determinar el marco
de las urnas y resolver los problemas de
seguridad que aquejan al país
y estamos convencidos de que al final de
esta misión y de la que pretendemos
emprender con la cedeao habrá un
verdadero punto de inflexión positivo
con nuestros socios pero también para
atraer de manera definitiva la paz y la
seguridad a nuestro país
[Música]
las autoridades de transición dijeron
que los desafíos de seguridad eran su
prioridad mientras que dos tercios del
territorio de mali escapa al control
estatal y la amenaza yihadista está
creciendo los dos golpes de estado de
agosto de 2020 y mayo de 2000 21 sólo
agregaron incertidumbre a la crisis que
atraviesa este país